hi my name is John rehab and my
colleague Petrova we are presenting the
book waste problem it's the problem
developed by Czech aristocrats Fukui who
was the first bubble in which
investigated mechanical system with a
varying mass mass in 1812 he explicitly
formulated the correct dynamical
equation of motion for the case when a
moving object mass is changing the
object is the following consideration of
idea a flexible fiber like real on a
horizontal plane the determine its
motion when a constant vertical force is
extracted on the end of the fiber this
motion is described theoretically and
simulated using confirm Mathematica has
been shown Marber this motion is
successful realize experimentally
experiment eita are compared with
theoretical results thanks
okay good afternoon everybody I'd like
to start by thanking you all for coming
to our table today
my name is Papa shatrova and when my
colleagues name is Yong jeha we work at
Party University in all modes in the
Czech Republic we are going to talk
about mechanical system with varying
mass specifically about the book voice
problem at our university we solve this
topic as a student project to start with
I will briefly explain basic principles
of the book voice problem after that my
colleague will continue with explanation
of an experimental arrangement and
comparison of experimental data with
simulation so let's start with a
historical background the problem we
will talk here is associated with the
name of count graph
George phonebook Roy he was Czech
aristocrat really well educated and
gifted gifted inventor McCoy was born in
1781
he was the first who investigated
mechanical system with known constant
mass in 1812 he explicitly formulated
the correct dynamical equation of motion
for the case when the mass of the moving
object is changing in 1815 he presented
his result at Pilate occur at Paris
Academy of Science to the leading
scientist of the time such as Laplace
person or Fourier his ideas did not
attract attention and soon became
forgotten
so the first explicit example of a
system with a varying mass suggested by
buco in 1814 is the following consider
an ideal flexible fiber lying grilled on
a horizontal plane determine determine
its motion when a constant vertical
force is exerted on the end of the fiber
so denoting the position of the end of
the fiber about above the horizontal
plane by X greater than zero we make the
following little simplifying assumptions
the vertical gravitational field is
homogeneous the fiber is thin and it's
linear density at ax is constant the
fibrous off without friction at the
origin of the x axis during the upward
motion the fiber smoothly disappears at
the origin of the x axis during the
motion downward that is the part that
has already landed on the plane does not
move the problem could be modeled
experimental as a vertical motion of a
balloon with a heavy rope hanging down
so the motion the motion of the fiber is
determined by Newton's law where P is
the momentum of the moving part of the
fiber F greater than zero is vertically
upward oriented constant force and mass
multiplied by the gravitational constant
is the oppositely exerting weight of the
real relink fiber suppose supposing the
mass is given by a de x X where a de is
constant linear density of the fiber
therefore the equation of motion has the
following form in equation two and after
a modifying form of free stationary
solution represent the equilibrium
situation such that the end of the fiber
is situated at a constant high it's
equation four so it seems that the
problem may be reduced to finding the
solution of equation three however this
equation only describes the upward
motion of the fiber it is only correct
form a growing X it means that the first
time derivation of X is greater than
zero the reason is that only in such a
case the resultant force is responsible
for the rate of change of the total
motor momentum of the fiber the first
term in equation 5 corresponds to a
velocity change of the already reeled
off part of the fiber which has the mesm
the second term expresses the part of
the momentum which in the time has to be
delivered by the resultant force in
order to give velocity to a piece of
fiber of mass lying at rest on the plane
in this way the piece joints the moving
part of the fiber in the case of
downward oriented motion the situation
is different the appropriate rate
change of the momentum only corresponds
to the velocity change of the already
reeled of fiber the second term in
equation 5 represents the rate of change
of the momentum of a piece of fiber
which with mass which in time lands on
the plane its velocity has to suddenly
decrease from the first time derivation
of X to zero however the forces
considered above are not responsible for
this change such a change is due to the
interaction between the fiber and the
plane therefore the second term in
equation 5 must be ignored when the
first time derivation of X is less than
zero thus we can write the equation of
motion in the flowing form 6 to look for
social for the first time derivation of
X greater than zero we can integrate
equation two to obtain the following
equation 7 where C is integration
constant depend on initial conditions as
following in equation eight equation
seven can be written as this following
equation nine when this term vef F is
effective potential for the case of
upward motion this may be formally
interpreted as a conservation law of the
thoth of total mechanical energy
corresponding to the motion of fixation
particle which unit mass in the force
field with effective potential
so there we have assimilation running
yes so substituting 9 2 equation of 3 we
obtain the following equation 10 where
on the right side on the right side here
other equation is effective for us then
we can make the following conclusion for
C greater than or equal to zero we
observe that effective force is less
than 0 and initial velocity must
necessarily be greater than zero
the initial condition of velocity equal
equals zero is only possible then the
effective force is greater than or equal
to 0 for any value of of the exerted
force there exist a maximum height X
became the solution X small M has the
meaning of the starting point of the
above the upward motion with zero
initial velocity
to look for solution for the first time
derivation of X less than zero we can
integrate equation six to obtain the
following in question eleven it it
follows these conclusions
for every potential level higher than
effective potential there exists two
turning points for which it is valid
following the coordinates of these
points fulfill the conditions 12 as you
can see on the graph here necessarily x2
greater than 0 therefore the upper end
of death fiber can never fall down back
on the plane so during the upward and
downward motion we can simulate the
complete motion if the downward motion
follows the upward motion
the turning point x1 is identical to the
max maximum value X Big M similarly the
turning point x2 becomes a new minimal
value X small m for a subsequent upward
motion to describe the complete motion
of the fiber we does have to alternately
join solution of equation 9 valid for
for for the first time derivation of X
greater than 0 with solution of 11 for
the first time derivation of X less than
0
so in our model the equation of motion
of 3 & 6 are written in United form the
motion of the fiber exhibits damped
quasi periodic oscillations small
oscillations are close to harmonic ones
it can be shown that the time interval
between two subsequent passages in the
case of upward motion decreases in time
while the analogous time interval for
the downward motion increases in time so
we have their simulations on the x-axis
is time which can we change maybe like
that and in this square we have initial
conditionals we can change it as you can
see
so now now it's my colleagues turn this
is a simulation of course we were
curious how this simulation fits to the
experiment first of all which we had to
arrange some experiment like this and if
you if you see internet for example
YouTube there's many there are many
experiments there are many school
experiments you can you can see but not
like not experiment like this so this is
this was also motivation to create some
experiment to arrange some experiment
like this I will show you recordings of
this experiment what we need we need a
smash point hariom filled ball some and
also some appropriate fiber because you
cannot arrange the experiment with some
light light fiber because we don't have
a drone for example for recording it's
some high altitude so we found some
appropriate metallic chain with with
good good linear density I will show you
this experiment
our colleague will come who teach school
experiments at our department
this is Janek
[Music]
and you can see these oscillations
for measurement of the movement of this
mess point we are using with our
students the freeware called tracker for
video it's freeware for video analysis
and this is a screenshot from this this
program it provides us some some extra
table or something of data of dependency
of the high of the ball on on time if we
upload at first the data we can show how
these oscillations based on the equation
in the theory how my colleague presented
you will see the final result no no I'm
sorry this is this is only only
downloaded data and and dependency on
high of the ball on time in the
experiment but in next slide we will
compare this experimental data with the
solution of this differential equation
the best fit we get is this one as you
can see this is not very good because
the oscillations especially damping of
oscillations is very very small smaller
than than the experiment and that's why
we think about it
that
this resistance on the on the ball
movement should be taken into account so
if we do this and look under on the this
experiment like small motion smaller
velocity motion of the ball we used
Stokes approach to to a resistance of
the movement
it means linear dependency of the force
of the earth residence force on velocity
this is this term and after several
arrangements you have to rewrite the
last differential equation to this form
so this term is additional for this so
if we use this this equation and again
compare the best fit with the experiment
we obtain this result it's much more
better than than the last one there are
some differences also but I think there
are many many errors during during the
experiments for example if you remember
the recording the movement it is very
very difficult to lock the movement of
the ball into line so it could be
probably the program may be some some
more errors too during the measurement
but I think this this result is pretty
good for us
and thanks for a - attention if you have
any questions
I don't think there is in the in the
room is the difference in density in the
air in two meters I don't think so
because we we we suppose we suppose
constant force to the ball we didn't
suppose it could change with high which
with attitude
that you plan it could be a problem I
think if you use light light fiber and
the movement will be much more high we I
think we should we should we should
no the problem is that this is the
simulation is numerical differential
solve number to solve of differential
equation so we try it but it was better
to do it manually since we see the
constants from from the from the
experiment but if you do it I think you
should you should use nonlinear model
fit and you have to two parameters to
set
okay thank you